[intro music]
[paddling sounds]
Good morning, John. It's Monday, February 12,
and I'm back in Montana. Can't you tell?
Actually, I'm probably on a plane right
now on my way to Montana.
Either that or I'm in Montana trying to chip through about 3 inches of ice that formed on my sidewalk.
This is pretty much the most beautiful day
that I'm going to see for a long time,
so I figured I'd make my video a little early so
you could see me in Florida,
doing Florida things, in a Florida hat, in
a Florida kayak, on a Florida intercoastal waterway,
surrounded by Florida birds, Florida fish, and
Floridians, aaanddd...
mmeee...
and Katherine
[paddling noises]
Well, it's official. You're going to be getting this
video blog while I'm on a plane.
I think it's the short leg, the one
from Denver to Missoula.
And I'm in Denver right now.
I am, as you know, a little bit of an amateur naturalist, and I'm a huge fan of birds
and also a huge fan of taking pictures of birds.
So I wanted to share with you some of the birds that I saw and took pictures of while on my "vacation.
tour of Florida."
Osprey, Black Crown Night Herons, Yellow Crown Night Herons, Little Blue Herons, Great Blue Herons,
Tricolored Herons, Snowy Egrets, Great Egrets, Cormorants, Anhingas, Ibis, Muscovy Ducks,
and, most awesomely, this Limpkin, who pretty much just danced around me
letting me take awesome pictures of it, even though they're one of the most rare species of bird in Florida,
and almost went extinct in the early 1900's.
I made another interesting discovery
while here in Florida.
While visiting my old college, I stopped by my old 7-11, and I found a beverage that you might be interested in.
Katherine and I are still on the yearly "tour of the entire Southeastern United States"
and I've been looking at liquor stores wherever I go trying to find
Boone's Farm Strawberry Hill Flavored Citrus Wine.
I'm at the 7-11 next to my old college and I have found Strawberry Hill. I'm about to buy it
so that I can complete the Strawberry Hill challenge, finally.
It looks really gross and it costs...
it doesn't say how much it costs,
but I only have 5 minutes left to buy it.
5 minutes to spare!
That's kind of exciting!
Man: Are you guys saying there's only
5 minutes left to buy beer?
Hank: Yeah.
Hank: Hurry!
Man: I better hurry and make my decision, huh?
Because you can't sell alcohol on Sundays in the state of Florida, so I have to buy this right now or else I'm not gonna get it.
Bye.
But you're gonna have to wait until Wednesday to see the completion of the Strawberry Hill challenge,
because I don't have time to edit it here in this airport.
So, you'll see me on Wednesday, drinking Strawberry Hill, and I'll see you tomorrow.